c'est vous qu'on voit dans les images
par terre est-ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'il y a un prêtre qui regarde ça et
qui ne réagit pas ce qui la négation
même de la religion catholique
aimons-nous les uns les autres
on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 28
Nathalie vigne rebondoire vous êtes né
le 9 mai 1971 à Villeneuve-sur-Lot
père chef d'entreprise mère institutrice
vous grandissez dans un schéma familial
assez stricte où les femmes sont
soumises
on peut dire ça comme ça vous allez à
l'école dans l'établissement privé
catholique c'est les bonnes soeurs
vous rentrez chez vous en vélo un homme
d'une vingtaine d'années vous suit vous
arrivez chez vous vous attrapez une
pomme dans le frigo vous allumez la télé
vous vous asseyez sur l'accoudoir du
canapé et à ce moment-là vous sentez une
présence l'homme qui vous suivait est
entré par la porte du garage il est
derrière vous il vous fait basculer sur
le canapé et vous dites t'inquiète pas
je vais pas te faire de mal
vous attraper un presse-papier pour le
frapper et il vous dit si tu me tapes je
te tue
je fais pipi à la culotte je crie et
j'ai l'impression que je un cauchemar et
mon corps comme si je me suis
décorporisée en fait et j'avais
l'impression de voir la situation et de
vous comme un cauchemar et au-dessus en
fait
j'ai hurlé je me suis débattue
il essaie de m'embrasser j'ai il a pas
pu parce que je leur poussais comme ça
il faisait mais comment tu t'appelles
pourquoi tu vas pas avoir une prostituée
comment tu t'appelles comment tu
t'appelles et à un moment donné je sais
pas comment je vais je lui ai chopé la
joue il y a vraiment l'empreinte de mes
dents j'ai vu l'empreinte de mes dents
je n'avais plus qu'à tirer la chair
venait et il a il a vu du sang couler
sur mon visage mais même rentrer dans la
bouche et il a il a fait comme ça il dit
c'est moi qui saigne et tout d'un coup
il a paniqué donc
et il laissait mis à courir partout dans
la maison à chercher la sortie en fait
et bon il m'avait arraché ma culotte il
m'a arraché mon pantalon et la première
chose que j'ai pu attraper c'était une
une lunette en fait de en cuivre et je
lui ai couru après je vais te tuer je
vais te tuer voilà
dans la rue oui alors évidemment vous en
parlez à votre mère vous avez au
commissariat les policiers veulent vous
montrer un de violeur et là vous refusez
de voir ça vous pouvez pas voir ça oui
je crois que c'est là où la difficulté
des des femmes à porter plainte en fait
après le après une agression sexuelle
c'est que on est on revit la chose on
est un confronté encore une fois à la
chose et finalement c'est une véritable
destruction
psychique et on ne sait pas en fait ce
qu'est le viol comme 90% des femmes vous
ne portez pas plainte vous dites j'avais
13 ans je ne savais même pas que j'avais
subi un viol j'appelais ça une agression
et vous avez fait comme si c'était pas
grave parce qu'en fait
j'avais pas réalisé que que la
pénétration était un viol en fait alors
vous enterrez le traumatisme le plus
profond possible et d'ailleurs quand
votre père rentre de voyage d'affaires
vous êtes tellement détaché apparemment
évidemment que j'y crois pas
c'est pas qu'il y croit pas c'est qu'en
fait il avait pas saisi que ça avait été
un viol il croyait que c'était juste une
agression alors vous continuez votre
scolarité sans problème mais sans
conviction heureusement il y a le
théâtre
à 18 ans Bac en poche ou monter à Paris
pour faire un BTS de Commerce mais très
vite vous allez au cours d'art
dramatique et vous commencez à
travailler de là vous faites des petits
films des pièces enfin ça commence quoi
j'ai commencé avec André téchinet dans
les réseaux sauvages alors à l'époque
effectivement à l'extérieur vous riez
vous parlez beaucoup par les forts en
fait tout ça n'est qu'une façade la
petite flamme qui s'est éteinte en vous
à l'âge de 13 ans ne se rallume pas quoi
voilà je vais de d'échec en échec mes
histoires d'amour sont catastrophiques
alors vous cherchez quelqu'un qui
incarne la justice mais vous tombez sur
des hommes qui ne vous veulent pas
obligatoirement du bien oui les hommes
qui peuvent être violents ou négligeants
surtout jamais bienveillant et jamais
aimant en fait
en fait dites-vous sans le savoir
j'allais vers les hommes qui me
faisaient peur
et les hommes qui me maintenaient dans
cette maltraitance dans cette dans cette
violence là aussi parce qu'elle était
souvent plus psychologique que physique
à 29 ans après une énième rupture vous
dites un garçon qui me traitait comme
une moins que rien vous décidez enfin de
consulter un psychothérapeute et ça va
durer sept ans
tous les jours
c'est très dur là
très très dur de remonter à la surface
d'agoraphobie c'est-à-dire vous ne
pouvez pas sortir et même quand on vous
frôle à l'époque vous ne supportez pas
le la présence des autres quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont empêché de passer à
l'acte
j'avais une pulsion de vie aussi qui
était très forte
alors vous rencontrez celui qui est
devenu votre mari avec qui vous êtes
toujours disant après deux ans après le
début de cette thérapie et vous dites il
a joué un grand rôle dans ma renaissance
oui parce que lorsqu'une femme ou un
homme parce qu'il y a aussi des enfants
qui masculins qui sont violets pour se
reconstruire s'ils ne sont pas aimés ou
s'il n'y a pas d'amour autour d'eux
c'est extrêmement difficile c'est
extrêmement dur
à 36 ans sortir de ce cauchemar
intérieur vous partez suivre des cours
de théâtre
à Los Angeles
Strasberg c'est génial la formation que
j'aurais aimé avoir à 12 ans
en France vous êtes libéré de vos
souffrances ça va beaucoup mieux et vous
avez quand même une envie de changer le
monde j'ai envie que cette violence
sexuelle
n'existe plus donc vous voyez j'ai de
l'ambition sexuelle
c'est le tout le mal qu'on vous souhaite
et c'est là que vous découvrez les Femen
alors ce qu'il faut dire sur les femens
c'est un mouvement féministe qui est
basé sur l'humour et la provocation qui
est née en Ukraine en 2008 alors on voit
souvent les Femen elles sont elles sont
les seins nus avec des slogans qui sont
écrits sur le corps ça ça fait partie de
leur
avec la petite couronne de fleurs aussi
les poussières c'est des Femen un peu
non tout à fait si vous n'aviez pas été
agressé sexuellement à l'âge de 13 ans
est-ce que vous auriez été fait même je
pense que je n'aurais pas été une
féministe ni une Femen aussi je vais
dire aussi
passionné quoi mais aussi parce que
j'étais élevée dans une famille où les
femmes étaient soumises donc elle permet
pardon mais elle fermait leur gueule
donc c'était l'homme qui parlait c'était
l'homme qui imposé et donc voilà donc je
prends aussi la parole pour ma
grand-mère je prends aussi la parole
pour ma mère
alors dimanche dernier vous participez à
la contre manif du mariage gay vous
saviez que ça allait être chaud
ça a été on regarde ce qui s'est passé
et sont allés au contact
un coup de fumigène déguisé en nonne
mais dénudé une dizaine de militantes de
l'organisation féministe FEMEN ont
attaqué le cortège des opposants au
mariage pour tous
on veste fluo le service d'ordre de
l'association Civitas à violemment
répliqué
au milieu des journalistes les
militantes ont reçu des coups au visage
et aurait été poursuivi et frappé par
des militants d'extrême droite
personne ont été interpellés
c'est vous qu'on voit dans les images
par terre est-ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'il y a un prêtre qui regarde ça et
qui ne réagit pas ce qu'il est négation
même de la religion catholique
aimons-nous les autres je trouve que les
les gens d'extrême droite qui ont frappé
ces filles nues on fait la preuve que
c'était des des
anormaux enfin de quelqu'un de normal se
masturbe
en plus c'est que c'est
pas des gaz lacrymogènes c'est des
extincteurs
c'est tout à fait inoffensif après quand
ils vous ont attrapé quand ils vous ont
rejoint vous êtes mis à genoux et on
leur a
donner tout l'amour qu'on avait en nous
ce qu'il faut intégrer aussi peut-être
c'est quelque chose dont on parle pas
suffisamment dans la société c'est que
la sexualité chez les jeunes hommes
passent beaucoup par la pornographie et
malheureusement dans la pornographie la
femme est un objet et on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui bien c'est le seul mode
d'entrée en relation amoureuse
avec une femme et ça c'est quelque chose
dont on parle à mon avis pas assez sur
lequel point de vue éducatif on n'est
pas suffisamment à mon avis pregnant et
sur lequel vous pouvez à mon avis
parfaitement parfaitement travaillé donc
bien sûr vous avez un mode de combat qui
est trash mais la cause est bonne et
c'est ça qui après tout et le principal
merci de votre témoignage en tous les
cas est-ce que je peux rajouter je
prépare deux spectacles de seul en scène
un basé sur l'inceste sur le livre de
Nathalie je fais Goffer j'avais 12 ans
et pour mon one human show qui est un
Femen show qui est très féministe aussi
métrage et drôle très drôle aussi et je
cherche mise en scène et production
voilà merci beaucoup Thierry et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu